this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history on this
episode we're back with bungie's sci-fi
shooter as jonathan takes a look at more
guns from destiny 2. i see what this is
now from first person view especially in
the reload i can see that this thing is
in fact a space tommy gun if there are
any other games guns mechanics that you
guys want to see jonathan breakdown let
us know in the comment section below and
make sure to subscribe as well as we've
got tons of content just like this on
the channel including loadout a show
where we take a look at the history and
impact of some of the most iconic
weapons in gaming but without further
ado let's take a look at the guns of
destiny 2.
so i'm looking at the
huckleberry
i'm not getting the significance of that
name so it's supposed to be a submachine
gun i am not clear on where the magazine
is
could be that red spirally fluted thing
on top i guess i'll find out it's got
horns
and a non-functional it's got a third
horn actually it's like a triceratops
it's got a nose horn that almost looks
like a front sight and may be meant to
be one i don't know but i can't see how
it would work as one for a trigger guard
it has the front grip
not ideal you could still accidentally
fire the thing i've noticed a distinct
lack of trigger guards in this game
maybe we're all using magic to prevent
accidental discharge and a real
obsession with thumb hole stocks as well
like this has a it has a little like
like almost like a rifle stop and then
like a railing
linking it to the pistol grip that
technically technically makes it a thumb
hole stop another very interesting
design though
right so yeah this is definitely meant
to be i guess a bit like the pp19 with a
helical feed magazine only it's mounted
well i guess it crossed between the p90s
magazine position and the bezon's
magazine design in that it's a spiral
feed but in this case the whole magazine
rotates making it a bit more like a
revolver it's kind of all those things
together we've then got a very
interesting reflex sight with art design
built into the reticle so you'll notice
with with modern military firearms
there's very little in the way of
decoration there might be an aesthetic
to it but you generally don't get
decoration some some of the sporting
versions of the same weapons can be
decorative this game goes all out on the
physical decoration this is the first
time that i can remember seeing
decoration in graphic form in
a site beautiful to look at doesn't help
you aim worth a damn though
unfortunately but it's something new
i've not seen before
seeing this thing in action so this has
got a special ability the longer you
hold down the trigger the higher the
rate of fire gets now those of you of a
certain vintage like me will remember
quake 2 and the version of the chain gun
and that worked just the same way and
the trade-off is the same here as well
where the more you hold it down the more
volume of fire you're getting but the
more you have to correct for the recoil
as it accumulates which is somewhat
realistic
not not a gun speeding up
the longer you hold down the trigger
guns can vary in rate of fire if
ammunition is if they're driven by the
ammunition like a like a maxim gun and
the ammunition is old varies in power or
is just not consistently loaded that can
make them stutter the rate of fire will
go
like that go up and down that's not a
design feature that's a bug it's there's
no advantage in designing a gun with a a
cumulative rate of fire it's a
deliberate game handicap to offset the
potential which is the high you know the
ultimate high rate of fire if you can
keep it on target for a whole magazine
you're gonna get more shots on target
but you also have to fight that
simulated recoil it's a real really fun
gameplay mechanic for a gun without much
basis in in reality
right i'm getting major halo vibes from
this thing which is unsurprising given
the developer of the game i cannot in
good conscious uh tell you that this is
my joke but um somebody has suggested
that this looks like someone's dropped a
lego pulse rifle down the stairs and
then trying to put it back together
without the instructions which i thought
summed it up pretty much perfectly the
only thing i'd add is well there's a
very p90 slash hero arms
ar15 furniture
feel to that curved foregrip in front of
the trigger and at the carry handle
looks like someone's taken a direct
queue from the one on the famous but the
overall effect is like a sort of
alternate halo assault rifle almost well
it's quite got some quite clean lines
but then quite a lot of detail in places
as well it's got that classic halo very
short reciprocating cocking handle
action and that classic halo very
20th century looking optical sight on
top of an otherwise very sci-fi looking
gun which is a bit of a quirk of
bungie's stuff it's very sci-fi reticle
in that conventional looking optical
site i'm not sure of any functionality
in that reticle that's often the case
and then we actually have a little radar
type screen on the side of the gun that
you can't see when you're aiming down
sights but it does allow you so i
understand to keep using your mini radar
in the top left of the screen whereas
aiming down sights with all the other
weapons in the game that disappears
because you're in your sights so that's
a quirky little bonus feature of this
weapon that's only represented on the
physical model of the weapon you're not
looking at that it's not like the
heartbeat sensor in modern warfare 2
where you can actually see that on
screen so that's a curious
design choice
right these needed some explanation uh
but
so it's a pair of weapons used in tandem
hence they've got a lanyard attaching
them together that's normally a lanyard
so that you don't lose the weapon so
typical for pistols if people are
operating out of vehicles or in the old
days an officer would have a lanyard on
his pistol so that if he's forced to let
it go he can reel it back in and doesn't
have to go looking for it here it's more
symbolic than anything else this is like
a these weapons are like twins you have
the symbol there of the two twins
holding hands and then in terms of what
the weapons are we've got at the pistol
gold pistol is
in silhouette a type 14 nambu it's got
most of the design cues in silhouette of
that gun the the protruding trigger
guard the the skinny barrel the bit
overhanging at the back is very
reminiscent of the back of the nambu the
magazine the the luger style discs that
you grasped with finger and thumb to
remove the magazine there there and then
all of the angles of the number there as
well the
other gun which appears to be inspired
by another axis powers weapon it's like
someone managed to butcher an mg-42 into
a pistol but kind of without reference
to any other period german weapons so
yeah yeah very much further removed from
its source material than the
pistol and then that has a magazine
catch in exactly the same location but
does not have a magazine in the pistol
grip they do both have the same grip
angle the same grip plates with the
thumb rest so there's been some thought
put into the design of these but the the
big thing what seems to be some sort of
box magazine
belt fed hybrid is the much more
fantastical
half of this pair let's see how they do
okay not what uh what i was expecting
there i have to say i thought the the
weird slightly mg 42 looking uh pistol
would turn out to be like a machine
pistol with like a nod toward belt feed
high rate of fire but no and that is
like the the hand cannon of a pair of
pistols where the gold one is a
conventional pistol and the the blue or
black colored one is like a hand cannon
fed by a big box magazine from
underneath slightly thrown off there by
the the slight resemblance to that uh
stamped metal top cover on the mg-42 it
doesn't really have much in common with
that gun whereas the gold pistol
absolutely is a reference to the
japanese nambu
the inevitable minigun chain gun has
sure enough appeared it is quite a
distinctive design in that it is in a
rifle format we have seen that before
although games will normally default to
your terminator 2 predator you know the
more sort of heroic stance of of um
separate grips they'll normally go for
that so like a vertical grip on a pistol
grip on on the back and some sort of
cross horizontal grip at the front uh
this has sort of got the horizontal grip
on the side but the format of it is a
shoulder stock a thumb hole stock again
this game is obsessed with thumb hole
stocks and then there's a sort of the
supporting receiver of the gun comes out
and supports those rotating barrels
quite a distinctive take on the classic
chain gun i do the scare quotes because
a chain gun is is a gun driven by a
chain
uh it's it's nothing to do with whether
it has multiple rotating barrels or not
in fact the the actual guns called train
guns in real life
don't have multiple barrels i'm sure
there are some multiple barrel guns
driven by chains
but you see what i mean
watching this thing in action that
horizontal grip is appears to be a
trigger as well so it moves it slides
you pull it back it's it's letting you
hold the gun somehow because it's very
heavy and it's also activating the gun
that that's a poor idea if this was real
simply because the weight of the thing
you moving about you're going to end up
both ways round basically firing when
you don't want to and not firing when
you do want to be firing in first person
review this is uh very reminiscent of
the quake 2 chain gun yeah this is a
stretched out look rather than the squat
mean look and it has the spool up spool
down rate of fire element as well again
i think probably inspired by quake 2.
then the reload i think for me is the
most interesting thing about this gun
you're replacing the effectively the
breach that contains rounds and putting
it behind rotating barrels i don't get
that the point of a gatling type gun is
that the breach the breaches the
multiple breaches are part of an
assembly with the rotating barrels and
they all turn together and they are you
know rounds are fed into those
breeches and the bolts one after the
other reciprocate to fire one round
after another so i don't know why you
would abandon that and
complicate life for yourself by limiting
your capacity well i do know why it's it
does solve the problem of having to
carry around a backpack full of belted
ammunition in theory but it would
drastically limit the ammunition you can
carry and mechanically it's going to
make it much more complex to try to
match the rotation of the barrels with a
totally separate magazine unit that's
also your breach super expensive as well
because it's it's how
part your magazine is also about 30 of
your weapon
so this this is like having replaceable
revolver cylinders those are quite
expensive to machine or they used to be
and even today a lot more expensive than
a speed loader so you don't generally
swap revolver cylinders you wouldn't do
the same here
well the the ubiquitous destiny thumb
hole stock has been taken to some
interesting extremes here we've got it
like a fishtail butt almost looks like
uh i don't know like a like a moroccan
pattern of matchlock musket like a big
fish or actually an english civil war
era musket would also have that
fishtail buttstock that this thing has
but then that there's a huge chunky
thumbhole stock with what looks
disturbingly like teeth in it i don't
know what those nubbins do a weird kind
of angular
design architecture what looks like a
fake selector switch on the left hand
side that looks like it wouldn't move if
you
tried a really
interesting almost not celtic not work
design drum magazine or is it an energy
device i'm gonna find out then there's a
foregrip and then there's a really
intricate lattice work barrel with some
long rods around the outside of it they
have gone to town on this thing so let's
have a look
i see what this is now weirdly enough in
profile it didn't really resemble it but
from first person view especially in the
reload i can see that this thing is in
fact a space tommy gun so that the drum
is i mean is reminiscent of that anyway
the grip frame is quite similar to the
thompson the shape of it it's
sufficiently designed that you know it
is just a design cue it's not a direct
lift but the overall effect is the rate
of well sort of the rate of fire that's
a bit slow the cocking handle on the top
the way it's held the big the big dinner
plate drum it it does have a thompson
and the foregrip of course it has a
thompson vibe to it and then there's a
an overheating mechanic here not only
does it overheat normally the the
penalty of overheating as you all know
is that the gun will stop firing
temporarily and some games will have you
go oh wow that's hot as part of the
animation this actually physically
damages you as it overheats which is
quite innovative and interesting this
gun also has what i would it's not meant
as an insult but bungie syndrome where
it's super high tech and like
electrically powered and like the you
know the feed devices beyond anything we
can imagine
and then it kicks out brash shell cases
so it's like
they can't move past that idea of the
self-contained metallic cartridge even
with these very high-tech looking guns
right this thing is called the multi-max
ccx but this pinged a little flag in my
head immediately because it is again
kind of the silhouette not the not the
design of the russian pp2000
submachine gun machine pistol
distinctive slanted front grip the
general configuration the overhanging
receiver and the little stock on the
back you compare this to the pp2000 that
the inspiration is pretty clear but it
is not a direct copy for one thing it
appears to have been married with the
gas system or a gas system reminiscent
of the kalashnikov so it has a gas block
looks really quite similar to an ak then
it has what is clearly based on an ak
top cover and i think an ak bolt in
there as well and i've just noticed it
even has the little star-shaped rivet
reinforcement features of the akm
receiver with that with the rivet in the
center of the two now one of them is
actually slightly off the bottom of the
gun oh there's also what looks like a
milled milled receiver ak lightning cut
so i think we've got multiple ak design
cubes that have been grafted onto this
pp2000 silhouette quite interesting when
you can spot the actual design keys that
have been referenced
so watching this thing shoot the
gas system i don't think can be
functional because the bolt is for is
actually a
an open bolt it's it's firing from the
rear it's on you know
sliding forward from the rear position
to pick up and fire around
like an actual open bolt would albeit it
has this weird stirrup over the top of
the receiver that doesn't make any sense
all i would do is induce drag um and be
a risk factor for for stoppages so but
but it looks cool moving back and forth
but that does mean that that what looks
like a kalashnikov gas tube and block at
the front
is presumably non-functional
maybe that's housing a rod that is part
of the bolt's mass okay so there is a
curious
design feature that sort of works um or
woodwork in reality and that's that
rather than the
like a fixed cocking handle like a
kalashnikov where it's it's part of the
bolt and it moves back and forth in
modern terms it means you have to flip
the gun over or reach underneath to
actually [ __ ] the weapon they've gone
for a machine pistol style cocking
handle on the top like an uzi or earlier
thompson where you would just have a
slit normally you just have a slit in
the receiver and the cocking handle
sticks out of that rather than do that
they have created arms that are part of
the bolt and the arch over the receiver
and your cocking handle sits on top it's
an innovative or an unusual at least way
to approach that problem and the fact
that they're even thinking about that
frankly is is quite impressive for a
game that's so far removed from the
reality of firearms that i don't think
has been done in reality because it is
always going to be more effective i
think to have the cocking handle
sticking straight up
out of a slot in the receiver than to do
it as a in this if you do it in this way
you're adding potential for
unreliability i think because if
anything gets stuck
under that arch you know that's that's
going to slow the bolt down cause a
stoppage so that's probably why you've
not seen that done in real life also to
machine a bolt with a thin arch over the
top of it it's probably not the optimal
way what you want is a solid lump of
steel and a separate cocking handle that
slots into it so but they are thinking
you can enjoy our own armory's channel
if you'd like to here on youtube we've
got various social media outlets as well
facebook instagram twitter if you really
would like to we have a donation scheme
and there's a link to that in the
description either way i'll see you guys
again next time
[Music]
you